en france après deux semaines d'un
parcours parlementaire mouvementée le
pass vaccinale a été définitivement
adoptée à l'assemblée nationale hier
soir une soixantaine de députés ont déjà
saisi le conseil constitutionnel
alors que les députés débattent et vous
le voyez dans l'hémicycle des dizaines
d'opposants ont manifesté devant
l'assemblée nationale il y a eu vous
voyez toujours à l'image quelques
accrochages avec les forces de l'ordre
présentes en nombre sur place le nouveau
pass vaccinale qui devrait entrer en
vigueur en fin de semaine selon le
gouvernement alors avec quelles
modalités on va voir cela tout de suite
avec notre reporter katia pique nique en
direct de l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
bonjour katia en quoi va à quoi va
ressembler ce nous se passe vaccinale
désormais
alors cette impasse vaccinale qui fait
des bains vous venez de le dire avec de
nouvelles restrictions alors déjà je
vais parler un peu de ce parcours en
deux pas du passé vaccinale après
quelques atermoiements l'assemblée
nationale a adopté définitivement ce
projet loin sur le passeur vaccinale
hier les débats ont duré deux heures et
demie 215 députés ont voté pour et 58
contre la majorité certains députés ps
et l air se sont prononcés pour tandis
que est reine et et la france insoumise
n'ont pas ratifié ce texte la lecture
définitive de ce projet de loi aura lieu
aujourd'hui à 16 heures alors qu'est ce
qu'il signifiait bien qu'il faudra
justifier son statut vaccinal pour aller
dans les bars les cafés les restaurants
les activités de loisirs certains
publics certains certaines n'ont pas
dans tous les transports d'ailleurs
inter régionaux fini le test négatif
sauf pour entrer à l'hôpital à noter car
c'est un seul point qui a fait consensus
quasiment c'est que on pourra le
présenter à partir de 16 ans tandis que
de 12 à 15 il faudra juste présenter un
pass sanitaires à l'ars et le 12e texte
ali terme et la navette parlementaire a
connu quelques écueils 1 tout d'abord
des suspensions de séance à l'assemblée
notamment à cause des propos polémiques
d'emmanuel macron faisait avons tous en
tête les sénateurs ensuite souhaité des
modifications notamment sur des
questions de contrôle d'identité ou
encore de sanctions en cas de non
respect du télétravail eh bien ils n'ont
pas réussi à s'entendre avec les députés
en commission mixte paritaire dont il a
eu en échec de nous retards et donc la
majorité espérer qu'il entre en vigueur
le 15 janvier mais ce n'est pas le cas
et pour continuer actuellement vous le
disiez les députés de la france
insoumise rejoints par quelques
parlementaires de liberté et territoires
notamment vont saisir le conseil
constitutionnel sur le pass vaccinale il
faut 60 députés pour le saisir et bien
apparemment le nombre a été atteint les
sages devront donc statuer sur la
validité constitutionnelle de cet outil
évaluer s'il contrevient ou non aux
libertés individuelles donc pour
l'entrée en application et bien il n'y a
pas encore de date précise mais fin de
semaine c'est ce que dit en tout cas le
gouvernement il l'espère merci beaucoup
catia pour toutes ces précisions katia
pique nique en direct de l'assemblée
nationale ce matin
[Musique]